nach re wieder kleine einfach richtig
das geil es ist einfach geil das beste
spiel und zwar clever was wir heute
machen wir spielen heute mario in zwei
teams als wir machen so competitive und
zwar wenn ich mit dem lieben peter
federlein team und baby ist mit rio in
einem team und wir wären einfach so
spielen wir spielen zehn minuten uncut
und schauen wer nach zehn minuten das
größere team volumen hat sage ich mal
also dann kombinieren wir uns einfach
mit dem genau mit den höheren score und
ich will einfach sagen ich bin bereit
ich bin bereit ich bin schon ganz nah
dran
perfekt also auch übrigens damit erst
ganz überprüfen können wir nehmen alle
auf check einfach alle channels die
verlinkt
ok dann drei zwei eins
ich will sagen einfach wir nehmen es
zählt dann am ende der score unten links
ich habe gestern auch kompliziert aber
aber geil
es ist das beste spiel das game 1 210
was sie gefressen perfekt alter hast du
ich auch da wollen wir uns unten links
in die ängste dass mit ihm können
ein köder er heißt köder einfach das ist
einfach richtig geil weil okay ich bin
gespannt
walter mit wo bist du bist du bist du
ich gehe jetzt nach unten
ich gehe nach unten links ja auch ich
wurde gefressen verfügt wird was ich
gehe nach unten links in die ecke peter
komm du auf deiner keine team ok peter
erwartet doch mal ich komme ich wo gehst
du ri
verpiss dich alle hebe ich will dich
retten
du kannst dich retten ich will euch
dauern komm schon flächen stefan oder
später kommen nach unten der kombi oder
schnecken nein du bist nicht da sehr
großer sichtung von mir also weiß nicht
markant wenn man kleiner ist als dieses
feld ich weiß ich hab da was passiert du
bist du denn
lasst uns mal treffen irgendwo wir
müssen dann sagt wo du bist oben links
mitte was ich bei mir ist rumänien okay
ich komme ich komme ich komme nach unten
links unten links pre wie du weißt wohin
müssen
ihr habt mich mit meiner größe also mein
gott oh mein gott man angefressen 140
punkte habe ich bin locker zielgröße von
uns jungs wir sind so viele alter
unten links fehler wo bist du wir können
was sind eure scores bisher eigentlich
ich habe das revier
josef ackerl wir müssen die kriegen
peter entwickeln
dieser kleine kreis ich viel zu lange
wie man das denn so schnell wie das
peter ich kann nicht helfen ich bin zu
klein wollen wir uns treffen jungs seien
ja nein du kannst du die fressen der
kinder waren schon da mit dem abfassen
hier
ich möchte daher ist der gott ich will
dir helfen wenn du mir sagst du bist
einfach fahren der kante endlich du
musst komm ich sag doch die ganze anlass
treffen
also ich gehe jeder gab es da bist du da
bist du bleibt einfach bei mir der nähe
wir machen jetzt richtig schön teamwork
und wir können hier noch aufholen ich
weiß nicht wie lange schon spiel
dann werde ich wieder zu einem größeren
wie lang dauert das 1 0 war das nix als
eine minute dauert das nein verfickte
scheiße viola okay ich wollte den
kriegen aber die großen maler
hundehalter du bist du richtig ausrasten
richtig gut
gib mir ein fressen ist aber nicht nur
eine wette gefüttert von dem pärchen
was soll das denn steaming rausgeworfen
für mich ich bin relativ gedrängt alter
tut eure hand nicht davon auch mit dem
spiel was soll denn der weg tun denken
immer hält es auch mit voll entspannt
was unseren sohn dpi von drei
eingestellt am 21 ich habe 7 145 grad
ich bewege mich wieder so noch nach
unten links
ich bin zu jung
dazu haben zum glück nicht
da muss man keine hoffnung ich habe mich
geteilt aber ich habe nachher wieder
kleiner
er hat sich einfach richtig die nicht
kriege ich hab dich nicht mal bekommen
weil nicht geopfert 745 kein problem wie
immer wieder gerne übrigens ist der
schlechteste den ich je gesehen habe ja
600 600 das geht noch mal richtig grad
geht noch mal richtig dass spanien als
scheiße ich war richtig eigentlich
komplett koduri ich bin auf 668 da bist
du da bist du der will mich da wenn mich
hier ja wir wollen die holen
8 da und kommt eine jetzt gar nichts ihn
ja sehr schön sehr schön
peter ich geb dir mal ein bisschen was
ab
und jetzt erstmal eine kleine private
passt passt fast acht klassen lasse mich
auf dieses spiel wer hat das gemacht
alter um mein gott ich bin schon ein
wie knapp
wenn du gefragt wie knapp ich verstehe
dass mit dem auto nicht wie kann man
jetzt sagen dass die eine blase dahin
schießen soll israel immer noch so
riesig die sich lieben peter rapp ist
sind gleich durch eine gleich sind zehn
minuten rum wird was ist sein score
zurzeit rio de sag mal 800 54
was hast du für ein peter beckmann
nein nein du bist es nicht ich werde
dort vorn haben nicht wirklich oder wenn
er als gut wir locken jede geht mal
wieder zusammen
das dauert ein bisschen bis wenn deine
zellwände aufgeweicht und helfer
okay wir probieren hier unten welche zu
kriegen wenn du wenn wir da ein bisschen
was abstauben
peter ist halt so zusammen jetzt kannst
du zusammen ok wo die region wäre ohne
kommt schon holen ich hab mich geopfert
data becker
kriegen wir egal egal nicht trotzdem
größer sie sind größer wir haben wir was
hast du für richtig
zehn minuten sind rum
13 14 wie ja ich bin grad verkürzt am
ende gestärkt worden mit über 200 noch
was 114 ihr meiner ist 80 jetzt gerade
peter 1000 6063 874 rasiert alter so
krass wie haben die ersten fünf minuten
takt bei mega lustig mega mega lustig
doch der check die anderen aus ich werde
auf jeden fall zusammen schlagen die
pause